ich arbeite ungefähr 60 stunden pro
woche im büro ich habe einen kleinen
sohn und baue das obst und gemüse für
meine familie fast komplett selber an
und da kann man sich ja wahrscheinlich
ungefähr vorstellen dass das nur klappt
wenn der garten möglichst pflegeleicht
ist und wenn du wissen willst dass mein
geheimnis ist aber nicht weitersagen es
bleibt unter uns wie ich meinen garten
so pflegeleicht halte und so wenig
arbeit mit meinem gemüse habe dann bleib
mal dran und kommt am besten mal grad
mit
[Musik]
haye an die arbeit nur papa ein bisschen
presseseite dass unser garten so
pflegeleicht ist liegt einfach daran
dass wir mit sehr viel system gärtnern
und da möchte ich jetzt zehn tipps mit
ihr teilen die dir dabei helfen das
gleiche zu machen
[Musik]
wenn man erster tipp ist dass du einen
garten tagebuch führen sollte ist meint
der gartentage buch ist schon ganz schön
zerfleddert so einfach so ein normales
schwarzes buch in das ich alles
reinschreiben was in meinem garten so
passiert ich schreibe da rein was ich
wohin pflanze welche sorten ich anbau
welche sowie besonders gut gefallen
haben welche nicht was für erfahrungen
mit schädlingen oder krankheiten gemacht
habe und dadurch habe ich eine viel
steilere lernkurve denn auch wenn man
denkt auch ich kann mir das doch alles
genau merken und nächstes jahr weiß ich
dass mir das nicht noch mal passiert es
ist doch so dass man einiges im laufe
der zeit wieder vergisst und wenn du dir
das stattdessen auf schreibst und die
jeden monat einmal die zeit nimmst deine
erfahrung alles was gut gelaufen ist und
was schlecht gelaufen ist in deinem
garten schwarz auf weiß festzuhalten
dann hast du einfach eine sehr viel
steilere lernkurve wird sehr viel
schneller eine weise gärtnerin oder ein
weiser gärtner mit einem ganz großen
erfahrungsschatz der die dann auch
wirklich was bringt tipp nummer zwei ist
das gärtnern ohne umgraben das spart uns
immens viel arbeit nicht nur das wäre
wenn wir beete anlegen nicht um graben
müssen was haben ist sehr anstrengend so
dass es also schon eine riesen
arbeitsersparnis aber du hast auch viel
weniger probleme mit unkraut wenn du
ohne umgraben gärtner und tipp nummer
drei die beete die schüler am haus
liegen wo du ganz oft vorbei kommst du
immer im blick hast was gerade reif ist
was gerade gemacht werden muss
funktionieren wie viel besser als beete
in einer ganz entlegenen gartenecke wo
du nicht regelmäßig daran vorbei kommst
du keinen überblick hast was da
eigentlich gerade passiert da kann es
dann auch sein dass du ganz einfach
vergisst die sachen zu ehrenden weil du
nicht mitbekommt wenn sie reif sind bei
vielen gemüse muss man das ja auch
ziemlich genau takten da hat man nicht
so ein großes fenster zum beispiel bei
brokkoli da muss man da hinterher sein
mit dem ersten damit man dann eben auch
schöne köpfe ernten kann und nicht quasi
einen blumenstrauß von populis die
eigentlich schon wieder gelb geworden
sind oder anfangen ihre blüten
auszubilden das ist also ganz wichtig
dass man da versucht die flächen zu
nutzen die möglichst nah am haus in oder
möglichst 3
legen sind wo man auch regelmäßig vorbei
kommt und er nicht in den eckwerten hat
wo man keinen überblick hat was da
eigentlich so wo er sich geht
das merke ich immer ganz extrem an
meinen bieten dann hab ich euch ja auch
schon mal erzählt dass ich gerne nach
den aussagen von maria tun gärtnerei das
ist ein aussaat kalender wo alle gemüse
in vier kategorien eingeteilt werden
einmal blüten gemüse wie die artischocke
ich glaube ein anderes gemüse fällt mir
das überhaupt nicht ein
aber wurzelgemüse hat man da blattgemüse
also wurde gemüse zb die möhre
blattgemüse wie zb weißkohl und frucht
gemüse wie gurken oder tomaten und das
hilft mir nicht nur enorm dabei wirklich
schöne gemüse zu ziehen weil das meiner
erfahrung nach wirklichen unterschied
macht an welchen tagen man die gemüse
sieht sondern das hilft mir auch dabei
meine aussagen so zu bündeln dass ich
sagen wir mal nur einmal innerhalb von
drei wochen alle blattgemüse sehr weil
ich dir dann alle auf einen tag lege und
dann sehe ich die sowohl draußen als
auch in der anzucht bei mir aus und dann
habe ich das wieder erledigt und so
bündele ich meine aussagen so dass ich
dann nicht jeden tag rausgehen muss
heute wollte ich doch noch rote beete
sehen und dann morgen noch die möhren
und dann noch kartoffeln pflanzen
sondern ich bin der das überlege mir an
welchem tag passte es gut und dann mache
ich eben die kartoffeln die okkulte
beete und dem hören alle an einem tag
denn dessen wurzel gemüse da suche ich
mir ein wurzel tag aus und so hat man
viel weniger arbeit indem man das
einfach ein bisschen plant und bündelt
und die ausfahrten gebündelt erledigt
das ist wirklich ein riesen zeit spar
tipp gerade wenn du vielleicht ein
bisschen weiter entfernt wohnt und einem
garten und da immerhin kommen muss
lebensretter bei uns der nächste tipp
hat auch was mit planung zu tun denn
wenn du von vornherein eine gute
fruchtfolge in deinem garten ein hältst
und eine gute mischkultur dann hast du
es viel leichter weil du so ganz viele
schädlinge und krankheiten vermeiden
kannst in deinem garten auf ganz
natürliche und ganz einfache art und
weise eine fruchtfolge ist ja der frucht
wechsel von jahr zu jahr also sagen wir
mal im ersten jahr kohl auf deinen beten
stehen und kohl hat einige schädlinge
und krankheiten die da ganz scharf
darauf sind und dann baust du aber
erstmal fünf jahre etwas anderes in den
beeten an
darauf folgen sodass dieser
krankheiten die in den boden sind wie
auf kohlen spezialisiert sind überhaupt
nicht das bekommen was sie wollen und
ausgehungert werden und dann erst im
sechsten jahr aber aus der wieder kohl
auf dem selben bett an dann sind deine
beete wieder clean
du kannst nur in kohl an bauen ohne dass
der wieder hat von den krankheiten und
schädlingen mit denen du vielleicht zu
kämpfen hat es infiziert wird das ist
also die fruchtfolge so kannst du das
ganz natürlich und ganz einfach
verhindern und eine mischkultur bedeutet
einfach dass die pflanzen zusammen
pflanze die sich gegenseitig irgendwie
gut tun sagen wir mal
ja ich nehme immer als beispiel die
bibel und die möhre die tun sich gut
weil sie sich gegenseitig die schädlinge
vom leib halten also die möhre wird
gegen die zwiebel fliege und die zwiebel
wirkt irgendwie man fliege und alles was
du machen musst ist beide nebeneinander
an zu bauen also total simple total
einfach erfordert aber ein bisschen
planung aber ich verlinkte auch gerne
meine playlist zu anbauplanung hier oben
in der ecke ist gar nicht so kompliziert
wie man dass jemand denken kann und wenn
du dann schon dabei bist ein anbau plan
zu erstellen dann achte doch auch darauf
dass du die gemüse regelmäßig aus heißt
also dass du nicht einmal nur im
frühling dein salat pflanzt und dann
hast du den im mai oder juni ist er dann
erntereif dann kannst du den essen und
danach ist er abgeerntet sondern dass du
regelmäßig sagen wir alle vier wochen
neuen salatpflanze damit du dann auch
regelmäßig ernten kannst das ist
wirklich ein super tipp um das ganze
jahr über aus seinem garten ernten zu
können bzw
regelmäßig ernten zu können denn es ist
super frustrierend und unnötig hin du in
deinem garten einmal alles voll pflanzt
und dann hast du zu einem zeitpunkt eine
riesengroße ernte weiß überhaupt nicht
mehr wohin mit den ganzen sachen deine
nachbarn wohl nichts mehr von ihr wissen
weil du sie immer mit einem zucchini
belästigt und dann musst du ein paar
wochen später wieder im laden gehen um
dir deine sachen zu kaufen weil dann
alles abgeerntet ist und du deinen
garten quasi gar nicht mehr gebrauchen
kann
deswegen ist es viel schlauer die
aussagen so zu takten hast du regelmäßig
aus seinem garten ernten kannst so hast
du dann vielmehr von deinem garten wenn
du das von vornherein in deiner
anbauplanung so berücksichtigt so als
haben wir aber genug von der planung
geredet reden wir mal wieder über die
techniken die man im garten
anwenden kann und wenn du deine gemüse
aus siehst dann auch wenn es vielleicht
spießig ist sehr sie lieber in gerade
reihen denn dann kannst du viel
einfacher mulchen wenn da unkraut
aufgeht hast du das viel leichter
entfernen wenn du da einfach nur einer
mit der hacke durchgehen muss um die
sachen zu entfernen die um heute oder
einfach einmal den mulch zwischen den
pflanzen verteilen muss das ist wirklich
ein zeit retter ein lebensretter im
garten also immer schön gerade rein sein
auch wenn es vielleicht lustiger
spaßiger ist wenn man einfach mal hier
und mal da irgendwas anbaut würde ich
dir immer empfehlen für einen
pflegeleichten gemüsegarten die gemüse
einfach im rhein zu sehen
die compass beete sind ja darauf
ausgelegt dass du möglichst unkrautfrei
gärtnern kannst aber wenn doch mal um
kräuter aufgehen dann schwuppdiwupps
aber mit der hacke durchgehen und die
ganzen pflanzen jäten und das machst du
besser früher als später denn sind die
pflanzen wenn sie noch klein sind viel
einfacher zu retten denn große pflanzen
muss man ja oft auch mit wurzeln
ausgraben bei den kleinen geht das viel
viel schneller und b können sich die
unkräuter ruckzuck aussehen in deinem
garten und dann hast du nicht nur ein
unkraut bestehen sondern gleich mal eben
wirklich viele unkräuter werden ganz
ganz viele samen und das solltest du auf
jeden fall verhindern
da hast du viel viel viel weniger arbeit
mit wenn du da einfach regelmäßig
hinterher bleibst und ihr habt es euch
wahrscheinlich schon gedacht ein
weiterer ganz wichtiger tipp um einen
pflegeleichten gemüsegarten zu haben ist
der muss man braucht eine dicke
mulchschicht finde ich zumindest es gibt
natürlich auch viele leute die uni hat
man aber ich finde das ist super wichtig
wenn man einen pflegeleichten
gemüsegarten haben euch da deren der
mulch unterdrückt unkraut hält den boden
feucht verrottet nach und nach zu dünger
also baut die humusschicht in deinem
boden auf und füttert und auch noch
nebenbei das bodenleben also da fühlen
sich dann auch regenwürmer und ganz
viele andere bodenkirchen superwohl in
deinem garten und das ist einfach ein
rundum-sorglos-paket wenn du deine beete
schön dick muss ist je größer die
pflanzen desto dicker kannst du dich auf
deine beete packen sie haben daher
teilweise bis zu 30 cm mussten
das ist wirklich ein
eine enorme zeitersparnis ich kann da
gerne noch mal ein video drüber machen
um das mulchen wenn ihr möchtet dann
könnt ihr mir gerne mal ein kommentar da
lassen wenn euch das interessiert man
kann das gerade in den biogarten auch
super wichtig dass sie ihren garten
nicht nur als rein nutzgarten betrachtet
sondern auch als lebensraum für ganz
viele nützlinge die euch weiterhelfen zb
indem sie schädlinge vertreiben von
höheren pflanzen
das ist nämlich eine wunderbare symbiose
und in gärten in denen es auch mal eine
wilde ecke gibt in denen es vielleicht
trockenmauern gibt auch mal ein
laubhaufen liegen bleiben darf oder du
vielleicht totholz in einer ecke lagers
zu dass ich da nützlinge etablieren
können neben du vielleicht sogar einen
tag ist ein tag ist ein super mit links
magnet da fühlen sich dann natürlich
auch nützlinge wohl die dir bei deinem
gärtnern ungemein weiterhelfen wenn du
zum beispiel ganz viele platten also in
deinem garten hast dann gibt es eine
ganze reihe von nützlingen die sich in
deinem garten engagieren könnten wenn du
ihnen denn den raum gibst sich da auch
niederzulassen und sich in deinem garten
wohl zu fühlen wenn du probleme mit
blattläusen hast kannst du dir übrigens
gerne mal da oben das video anschauen da
habe ich nämlich auch schon mal drüber
geredet also tipp nummer 10 ganz wichtig
nicht nur für dich selber gärten und
sondern auch für das ökosystem biogarten
und für die ganzen nützlinge die dir in
deinem garten so ungemein weiterhelfen
ich poste auf diesem kanal hier ganz
viele videos rund um das thema
gemüsegarten selbstversorgung und arbeit
sparendes gärtnern also wenn dich das
interessiert dann abonniere gerne meinen
kanal und wenn du wissen willst was du
machen kannst damit du in deinem garten
kaum noch gießen muss auch in heißen
trockenen sommer nicht dann klickt gerne
mal getrieben das video an ansonsten
verlinkt ich dir da unten auch noch ein
video dass dich interessieren könnte
wenn du ideen hast für andere videos die
ich machen könnte schreibt mir gerne
einen kommentar da freue ich mich an
gemeint rüber ansonsten sehen wir uns
nächste woche wieder das dann tschüss